[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to orbit report
you're a source for everything happening
around the world in pop culture and
entertainment news i'm heather ruse and
on Ayano aid and this is your news for
monday february 26 so first of all we
finally got a release date for that
live-action Sonic movie that's coming
out soon
actually well not soon it's about a year
and a half away it's gonna be November
19th 2019 so not this year but next year
I guess they're gonna try to get it with
the holiday movies a family a family
film it's gonna be a live-action CGI mix
which seems weird I don't I mean it's
supposed to be based on sonic adventures
I mean they're humans in that so I guess
it works cuz there's humans but also I'm
not sure we're really gonna need this I
don't know I'm not that excited about it
right now I'm actions it sounds a little
wonky it is a little strange it's
already been kind of done by a fan in
fact Doug Walker with and a fan film a
20-minute one that's right on YouTube
you can find it that did this exact same
thing so it'll be interesting too and
people didn't like that one so I don't I
don't know I'm really not excited about
it it's gonna be directed by Jeff Fowler
who doesn't have too many things under
his belt so we'll see how that works and
it's written by Pat Casey and Josh
Miller there's not any production photos
or anything else for it besides a
release date so they're happening it's
happening sometime in 2019 it's a family
film also introductions is another
live-action CGI mix good because we
didn't have enough of those but this one
is the Pinocchio yes that's right we're
getting another remake oh I know
nope not that cool guillermo del toro
stop animation when we were promised
that in fascist Italy that sounded
amazing no reading something else so we
don't know what yet because the script
already existed and now it's being
rewritten by Jack Thorne however I will
say the director tagged on makes a lot
of sense it's Paul King who did the
Paddington movies which have had great
acclaim and SS so maybe I'm a little too
quick to judge but here's the thing with
Pinocchio it could turn out amazing
award terrible yeah and so who knows
where this reboot will land right no
idea right we could do some cool effects
and stuff I think it a lot of its gonna
depend on the connectin but the casting
of Pinocchio very true very true so we
don't have any news on that yet we only
have the pre-production announcements
right now as it goes into the works but
I'm sure we'll be hearing more about
this movie I don't know they're Disney's
doing a lot of remakes live-action
remake so obviously with Cinderella
beating the Beast I'm getting Lion King
soon all of these a lot of them are
princessy but that's not fair
we're getting Lion King we just got
jungle book as well so it makes sense
that they're steering more towards you
know like everyone audience like no key
oh yeah I don't know it could end up
pretty bad so to say I'm not worried I
would be like so many things were
concerned about this week yeah another
Disney reboot that's coming your way is
on the streaming service they're
rebooting the Muppets yeah yeah so I'm a
little weary about this as well because
okay they did have not a reboot on eby's
we did and that one was a little cynical
and so it didn't late-night TV show ish
kind of the office mixed with it which
is not exactly what we were expecting
from a Muppets TV show right so it'll be
interesting to see if they're gonna take
that same direction and just kind of
make a second season of something like
that
or go back to something more whimsical
and magical which is what they did in
the movie
well the movies were a lot more
lighthearted and whimsical I would say
and so if they went kind of with that
route I would say this is gonna work
yeah again
Muppets reboot could go either way right
hoping good though because I love some
of it right and I hope they do kind of
capitalize on that whimsical nostalgia
for the Muppets because it is a little
bit more of what we're used to
absolutely I appreciate that with the
EBC
ABC series they tried to do something
new and unique but it didn't 100% play
the right way didn't quite find its
audience so hopefully this will find its
footing and its audience a bit more than
the ABC show did and again that's
happening on the streaming service in
2019 still unannounced the exact release
date of the streaming service or the
name of the streaming service even and
so that joins already some of the Star
Wars library and new Star Wars shows the
Marvel library and a new Marvel show now
Muppets and Disney library yeah I mean
this is gonna give Netflix a run for
their money let's be real it really and
a lot of the shows the newer stuff is
going to be going on the Disney service
instead of Netflix and that's still
coming out in 28 1919 and so once that
happens I think all of the Disney stuff
that's on Netflix is gonna move over
once the streaming service starts so
you're not gonna have it on Netflix
anymore now that some original stuff but
that's taken a good chunk of my binge
watching stuff away so we'll see also on
Netflix was announced this week that
lost in space is getting a reboot and
they released a little bit of a trailer
of the Robinson family walking into
their ship with a little bit of
voiceover I gotta say this makes sense
to remake especially in this time
because they're talking a lot cooler
means there's been a lot more effects
that we can do with some of the cool
like these things you know and so I'm
really excited to see what Netflix has
done with this and the trailer made it
look really cool it looks great yeah but
danger danger Will Robinson
the trailer did close with a little
danger
it needs to be fully because I mean what
why do it if you're not meant to it yeah
so that'll come out April 13th so we
don't have that long actually yeah yeah
also coming to Netflix is a questionable
reboot of reboot reboot of reboot which
is still kind of fun to say about
whatever um but this trailer was not fun
for anyone who is a fan of the original
series it's going to be called The
Guardian code so it's reboot the
Guardian code and that's coming to
Netflix like we said and I just this
trailer made me feel some anger that I
didn't know I had buried deep down
inside I was a huge fan of the original
series which by the way is a
groundbreaking CGI half an hour series
which now involves live-action why I
don't know it's now about four teenagers
who are going to Alan Turing high school
Shannon I role the most technologically
advanced high school in the area and
they all get assigned to homeroom zero
where they're digitized into the
computer to become the guardians of the
mainframe it kind of is you can see
they're trying to keep it somewhat
connected to the original and that
they're the guardians and they're in
mainframe but they don't look anything
remotely close to what the original
looked like now okay the original is a
little outdated by now by current
standards it is and it was kind of funny
to see the way that they portrayed
mainframe is very like early 2000s like
this is what we think the internet looks
like like I get it I know you can update
it a little bit but at least make it
look somewhat like the original it gave
me very spy kids vibes like early 2000s
we're all super into spy kids remember
that great times it's not the way very
much like that but you know like almost
and they had megabyte and in the trailer
as well who was the villain of the show
but no hexadecimal but fine whatever
oh they had megabyte and he barely
looked anything like the original I mean
I guess he had like the Chin's but even
the original seemed like it was more
detailed and cared for than this one so
that comes out on March 30th if you care
I might just rage watch it I don't know
but I am so angry about it I don't know
if you wanna watch the live stream the
reboot rebus okay here's the thing that
I'm just baffled by another Netflix show
it's okay so it's a camera social
experiment I would say with actors and a
bunch of hidden cameras and then one
person who's not an actor who is the
center of this social experiment and
this is what reality television has
evolved into making someone commit
murder that's right so the idea is
there's this whole plan to get this
person to believe the only thing left in
this whole scenario that they put this
person in is to push someone to their
death there's a show about that we
killing people now what it looks crazy
looks terrifying what have you done
internet I don't know well I watch it
absolutely right I need to know that
everyone doesn't commit the murder
we need to know inside of my soul that
there's hope goodness left I don't know
that that's how that's gonna work though
I don't know you know I used to watch
that show what would you do with the
home yeah yeah I loved that and he
usually made me cry because that I
remember
like humanity is amazing and they're
good and I don't know if this show is
gonna be like that because you're gonna
murder someone anyway if that comes out
on Netflix February 27 so tomorrow
hey yeah I'll be watching that back
don't kill anyone in the meantime please
don't
although if you want to follow us on
social media you can Heather where's
that for you you can find me on Twitter
at Heather ruse Instagram at a truce and
twitch twitch TV slash other ruse and
you can find me on Facebook as I gotta
wait and everywhere else as awesome
Ayanna don't forget to tune in to top 5
tomorrow where we may have a special
episode for you involving maybe where
Walter has been keep using that hashtag
hashtag where's Walter we might find out
sooner than you think
anyways in the meantime we'll see you
soon and can you
[Applause]
you